Le concept de fondamentalisme est essentiellement lié
au concept de mesure en mécanique quantique
avant que la mécanique des points ne soit développée
c'était une connaissance généralement admise
par les scientifiques que si tu as un système dans cet état
il sera dans un état bien défini
et si tu effectues une mesure dessus, tu vas obtenir
un résultat bien défini, c'est-à-dire déterministe
en mécanique quantique, ce n'est plus le cas, tu peux avoir
un système qui se trouve dans un état parfaitement bien défini
et pourtant, si tu effectues certaines
mesures dessus, tu peux obtenir des résultats aléatoires
alors pour illustrer ce concept, il vaut mieux que je
te présente le concept de superposition
la superposition est un concept qui n'est pas si bizarre
c'est basé sur le fait d'afficher
plusieurs combinaisons linéaires d'états
simultanément, et tu peux y penser
comme par exemple une onde radio qui porte
plusieurs fréquences différentes, il n'y a rien
de mystérieux là-dedans
ce qui donne à la superposition sa saveur quantique, c'est le fait
de mesurer le système
alors je vais l'illustrer avec un exemple
imagine que tu aies un système de flèches
et tu prépares le système
de sorte que toutes les flèches pointent vers la gauche
et ensuite tu vas et tu
poses la question existentielle : es-tu vers le haut ou vers le bas ?
et tu demandes à chaque flèche, parce que les flèches pointant à gauche peuvent être
exprimées, décrites
comme une superposition linéaire entre
haut et bas, tu vas obtenir
comme résultat cinquante pour cent vers le haut
et cinquante pour cent quand tu poses la question : es-tu vers le haut ?
tu obtiens ce résultat du système
et ensuite tu peux préparer
un état différent du système où la moitié
pointe vers le haut et l'autre moitié
pointe vers le bas, et tu poses la même question
et tu obtiens le même résultat
ce sont deux systèmes très différents
et tu as obtenu la même information
pour une masse de mesures maintenant
comment peux-tu déterminer quelle est la différence ?
les situations sont très différentes
parce que dans le premier cas, tu as préparé le système dans
un état pur, donc tu peux lui poser une question à laquelle
il te donnera une réponse déterministe
et non aléatoire, et cette question c'est : es-tu à gauche ou à droite ?
il va te dire cent pour cent à gauche
dans le deuxième cas, il n'y a aucune question que tu peux poser
pour lui faire donner une réponse à cent pour cent, parce que c'est un mélange
une réponse déterministe, parce que c'est un mélange
donc si tu demandes gauche ou droite
ça va être aléatoire, parce que la moitié est vers le haut
et l'autre vers le bas ; si tu demandes haut ou bas
pareil, ça va être cinquante pour cent
quel est le rapport avec l'aléatoire quantique ?
tu peux imaginer que c'est
similaire au fait de lancer une pièce, ça va être pile ou face
mais ce n'est pas comme lancer une pièce du tout
parce que quand tu lances une pièce
la seule raison pour laquelle tu ne sais pas le résultat que tu vas obtenir
c'est parce que tu ne connais pas
l'énergie avec laquelle tu as lancé la pièce, l'angle au moment du lancer
les conditions ambiantes dans la pièce
et ainsi de suite, donc si tu connaissais toutes ces
variables, tu pourrais prédire pile ou face exactement
ce sont des variables cachées à l'observateur
et pendant longtemps, les scientifiques ont pensé qu'il existait
des variables similaires en mécanique quantique qui
se manifesteraient sous forme d'aléatoire
et ce n'est qu'avec les
travaux fondateurs de John Bell dans les années soixante qu'il a été démontré
que ce n'est pas le cas
et maintenant tous les physiciens
reconnaissent qu'il n'existe aucune
théorie à variables cachées compatible avec la mécanique quantique
il est donc vraiment vrai que quand tu mesures un système
la nature révèle son résultat de façon
peu importe combien j'y réfléchis, je
continuerai à trouver ça incroyable